ya van a cuatro las a fugas detectadas
en los gasoductos nostrum 1 y nostrim 2
recordemos son dos gasoductos que
conectan Rusia con Europa ahora mismo
ninguno de los dos funcionaba cuando se
ha producido este supuesto Sabotaje el 1
De hecho no funciona desde septiembre
debido a supuestas cuestiones de
mantenimiento por parte de Rusia y el
nostrim 2 nunca nunca ha llegado a estar
operativo debido a que Alemania dejó
decidió que no funcionará justo antes de
que Rusia invadiera Ucrania estos dos
gasoductos preocupan enormemente tanto
la Unión Europea y a la otan hablan
abiertamente de Sabotaje aunque no se ha
señalado aún a ningún culpable Sí
insisten en que se trata de ataques
intencionados y que se va a responder En
consecuencia así lo ha asegurado los 30
aliados de la otra en un comunicado
conjunto dicen que la respuesta será
fuerte y contundente y que van a
trabajar en una investigación
para saber lo que ha ocurrido la otan
dice que va a actuar de forma unida y
que va a actuar en consecuencia aún no
se ha señalado aún a ningún culpable a
Estados Unidos y Rusia y han asegurado
que ellos no tienen nada que ver aunque
Ucrania y Polonia han asegurado que se
trata de Rusia quien está detrás